I have some fascinating video to dig in to
today. Donald Trump has been having trouble
on the issue of race lately. Donald Trump's
reaction to huge national protests against
police brutality after George Floyd was killed
by police was to say sending more force and
have the military dominate the protesters.
That was the word he used last week or the
week before and a call with governors. So
it's obviously not going well for Trump on
race. Donald Trump is polling eight percent
with black voters, eight eight percent, according
to a new CNN poll. So someone got the bright
idea. Let's send Trump to be interviewed on
Fox News, but not by one of their ubiquitous
white blond anchors. Have black woman Harris
Faulkner interview Donald Trump. This is gonna
be great. It's going to help him with with
black voters. It was absolutely and utterly
insane. And I want to look at some clips with
you today. Here's Trump pulling out the cringe
worthy claim about him doing more for black
people than any other president. And he weirdly
says, let's not include Lincoln in that, although
he adds. It is questionable how much Abraham
Lincoln really did for black people, to which
even Fox News anchor Harris Faulkner has to
say, well, we are free, Mr. President. Like
Lincoln freed the slaves. You've done more
for us to check out this first clip and a
strap in, folks, because it's gonna be wild
pitches in general.
I mean, the economy is the great unifier,
right? I think I've done more for the black
community than any other president. And let's
take a pass on Abraham Lincoln because he
did good, although it's always questionable.
You know, in other words, the end result.
We are free, Mr. President. But we all did
pretty well. You understand what I mean? I'm
going to take a pass on a a honest Abe, as
we call it. You say you do.
Absolutely bizarre. This is the president
talking like this and he doesn't even have
the historical understanding to be able to
recognize how Cringely, this is like it's
total cringe. But he doesn't get it because
he lacks historical knowledge. Trump, who
has defended Confederate monuments, says he's
done more for black people than any other
president. So then we get into the meat of
it, as it were, related to the protests. And
Donald Trump says and this really requires
some deep thinking to know what on earth is
this guy talking about? Trump says that police
chokeholds as a concept are innocent and perfectly
innocent and perfect. And then he totally
dissembles into nonsense.
Well, I am. And I think the concept of chokehold
sounds so innocent, so perfect. And then you
realize if it's a one on one now, if it's
two on one, that's a little bit of a different
story, depending depending on the toughness
and strength. You know, we're talking about
toughness and strength. We are talking there's
a physical thing here also.
But if a police officer is in a bad scuffle
and he's got somebody, if it's a one on one
fight for the lawyer and that's just happened
and that does happen. And so you have to be
careful.
What is he talking about? I'm not I'm not
asking rhetorically, what is he talking about?
Now, understand that there are lots of Republicans
who will say only eight percent of black voters
support Trump because they've been somehow
tricked by Democrats or they've fallen for
something which implicitly suggests black
voters are dumb, that they they've been tricked
by Democrats. Watch this interview. And you
understand why Trump is polling eight percent
with black voters. Here's more about chokeholds.
Trump saying sometimes bad people. Something.
Something chokeholds are good. That's I mean,
I have a hard time making more sense out of
it than that.
Say no, I don't want to see mistakes. Yes.
I don't like Joe calls. And I will say this
as somebody that, you know, you grow up and
you wrestle and you fight and you this or
you see what happens. Sometimes if you're
alone and you fighting somebody who's tough
and you get somebody in a chokehold. Where
are you? Is say, oh, and it's a real bad person
and you know that. And they do exist. I mean,
we have some real bad people. You saw that
during the last couple of weeks. You saw some
very good people protesting, too. So some
bad people also. And you did somebody in a
chokehold. And what you can do now. Let go
and say let's start all over again. I'm not
allowed to have you in a chokehold. It's a
tough situation. If you have two people or
the case and the case that we're talking about
two or four people and two of them, I guess,
just pretty much started. So it's a very,
very, very tricky situation. That's the sort
of chokehold thing is is good because to talk
about because off the cuff you it sound like.
Absolutely. But if you're thinking about it,
then you realize maybe there is a bad fight
and the officer gets somebody in a position.
That's a sliding scale. Depending on what
the circumstances. I think you have to probably
see you want to be in that conversation.
It's just not of this world. There's there's
nothing there. There's no substance there
to even really analyze another absolutely
Looney Tunes moment from this interview. They
get into the phrase Trump used. When the looting
starts, the shooting starts. Trump used this
phrase during the protests recently. The origins
are a guy named Walter Headly, the police
chief of Miami, Florida, who said it in the
60s when there was a violent outbreak of crime.
And it has a horribly racist history. It was
positioned against the battle for civil rights
in the country at the time. And Trump was
asked about the origins and he kind of plays
dumb. He's like, well, other people also said
it like Philly Police Commissioner Frank Rizzo
used the term. Now, Rizzo did not actually
use the term, but he did encourage brutal
police tactics. And Trump just kind of says,
like, well, Rizzo also said it, which is not
technically true. And then it gets just really
awkward if you if you have an aversion to
awkwardness, I would maybe skip the next two
minutes.
I mean, and I'm Paris on TV, but I'm a black
woman. I'm a mom. And, you know, when you've
talked about it, but we haven't seen you come
out and be that consoler in this instance.
And the tweets when the looting starts.
Shooting starts, why those words so let's
say an expression I've heard over the years
and Atena, it comes to, I think, Philadelphia,
the mayor of Philadelphia.
It comes from 1967. I was about 18 months
old at the time, everybody shooting Wicky
because they probably got it wrong.
But it was from the chief of police in Miami.
He was cracking down and he meant what he
said. And he said, I don't even care if it
makes it look like brutality. I'm going to
crackdown when the looting starts.
The shooting stars that frightened a lot of
people. When you talk, it also comes from
a very tough mayor who I might have been police
commissioner at the time, but I think mayor
of Philadelphia named Frank Rizzo and he had
an expression like that. But I've heard it
many times and I think it's been used many
times. It means two things, very different
things. One is if there's looting, there's
probably going to be shooting. And that's
not as a threat. That's really just a fact
because that's what happens. And the other
is if there's looting, there's going to be
shooting. This is very, very different meanings.
Interesting note has very different meanings.
But I think do you think most people see it
that way?
I think they see it both ways. No, I mean,
I've I've had viewed both ways. I think it's
meant both ways.
Can anybody understand what he's talking about?
Like, literally, what is he saying? I'm feeling
like my grammatical knowledge of English is
not up to par to properly pass what Donald
Trump is trying to say here. So let's now
go backwards a little bit. I'm going to go
back to the start of the interview with Harris
Faulkner. And Trump characterizes the protests
really as riots and unnecessary. Of course,
they were mostly peaceful protests and they
were totally warranted, given the inaction
on police brutality for so long, just completely
dismissive. Trump is of the entire movement,
not exactly an opportunity for a big coup
with black voters.
It's happened in the last couple of weeks.
I feel like we are at one of those historical
moments where future generations will look
back and they'll decide who we were. Are you
the president, to unite all of us? Given everything
that's happening right now?
Well, I certainly think so, and I certainly
hope so. And the relationships we have are
incredible, the spirit of this country and
especially considering what happened. And
we heard out of nowhere a plague come in from
China who just came in and it came to all
over the world.
It went all over the world.
You look at it, 186 countries. And they were
devastated. And we were certainly hit very
hard. Some were hit harder than us relatively,
but we were hit very, very hard. And now we're
making our comeback. And then on top of it,
we had the the riots, which were unnecessary
to the extent they were. If the governors
and mayors would have taken a stronger action,
I think the riots would have been you could
call the protesters, you could call them riots.
So different nights, different things, says
riots again.
Says riots again, says you could call them
protests, but they're really riots. And then
following up this dismissive dismissiveness
with even more. Remember, they sat him in
front of Black Fox News anchor Harris Faulkner,
I guess, as part of the optics here. And he
just says horrible things here. Trump says
lots of the protests that protesters didn't
even know why they were protesting, which
is just completely dismissive of the movement
when he called out mom on that tape.
It's a heart patch.
So I'm curious from you, what do you think?
The protesters, not not the looters and the
rioters, we were intelligent enough to know
the difference in our culture. Right.
What do you think they want? What do you think
they need right now from you?
So I think you had protesters for different
reasons and then you had protesting also because
they just didn't know. I've watched. I watched
very closely. Why are you here? And they really
weren't able to say, but they were there for
a reason, perhaps. But a lot of them really
were there because they following the crowd.
A lot of them there were there because what
we witnessed was a terrible thing. What we
saw was a terrible thing. And we've seen it
over the years. We have and, you know, this
was one horrible example. But you've seen
other terrible examples. You know, that better
than anybody would would know it.
Yes. Black woman Harris Faulkner would know
better than anyone. But again, protesters
didn't know why they were there, according
to Donald Trump. So, listen, you can find
people who were out there who were just trying
to cause trouble or going with the crowd.
But the answer is the overwhelmingly peaceful
protests were there because of police brutality.
You say that first. Not as an aside or at
the end, completely disastrous interview,
but to totally level with you. I don't know
that it matters. Anybody who would be disgusted
with. This interview is already not voting
for Donald Trump. Anybody who just watches
Fox News and gets in line and is planning
to vote for Trump is going to vote for him
anyway, regardless of this interview. So we've
got to hit that slice who might change their
minds. And I don't know that many of those
folks are actually going to see this interview.
It's tragic. It's sad because this is really
exposing the lack of critical thinking and
and sort of thoughtfulness and introspection
that Donald Trump experiences a total lack
of. And it's you know, if you really sit down
and listen to each of his answers, you understand
the guy understands nothing. He just knows
nothing. He doesn't even know he he's there
for a particular reason. There's a reason
that with what's going on, he's being interviewed
by Harris Faulkner and he still fails to keep
it together in the way that this type of strategy
would hope that he would be able to do. Just
absolutely insane. We're going to have more
clips from this interview on The David Pakman
Show Instagram, which is at David Pakman show
on my Instagram David Pakman. You can see
me at a socially distanced outdoor cafe over
the weekend.
An incredible moment. Just I just sat down
outside somewhere and it felt like a huge
thing. That's on my Instagram David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dot.com.